OK, so one of my co-workers, David Kestenbaum, started telling me about this thing. And really, I thought he was completely-- I just-- there was no way it could be true. It just seemed completely ridiculous. And then, I got to say, the more he explained, the more it slowly started to seem like, OK, maybe he's right.
好的，我的一个同事大卫·克 斯滕鲍姆（David Kestenbaum）开始跟我说这件事。说实话，我当时觉得他完全——我只是——这根本不可能。这听起来太荒谬了。但后来我得说，他解释得越多，我就越觉得，好吧，也许他是对的。
Important fact to know about David before we go any further-- he has a PhD in physics, worked at Fermilab on subatomic particles, was on the team that discovered the top quark. And then this whole thing between him and me began when he told me to download an app onto my iPhone.
在我们继续之前，有一件关于大卫的重要事实需要了解——他拥有物理学博士学位，曾在费米实验室研究亚原子粒子，是发现顶夸克的团队成员之一。后来，我和他之间的这一切始于他让我下载一个 iPhone 应用程序。
It's called Universe Splitter.
它叫“宇宙分裂器”（Universe Splitter）。
[DING]
[叮]
OK, so now I've opened it up. And there's, like, a gray steel, fake steel background. And it says in white type on top of it, Universe Splitter, quantum-induced universe bifurcation. What do I do now?
好了，我现在打开它了。它有一个灰色的、钢质的，假钢质背景。顶部的白色字体写着：宇宙分裂器，量子诱导的宇宙分叉。我现在该做什么？
All right, so tell me something you are having trouble making up your mind about what to do.
好的，那么告诉我一件你正在为难、难以做决定该怎么做的事情。
You and I are recording this on December 31.
我们是在 12 月 31 日录制这期节目的。
Yeah.
是的。
And I've had a week off. I grew a beard.
我休了一周假。我留了胡子。
I noticed.
我注意到了。
And I'm trying to decide if I should shave it off. And so that's something I'm trying to decide.
我正在考虑要不要把它刮掉。这就是我正在纠结的事情。
I have an opinion on that, but--
对此我有个看法，但是——
What's your opinion?
你有什么看法？
[LAUGHS] Actually, I think it looks pretty good right now.
[笑] 其实，我觉得你现在的样子挺好的。
OK, so what does this Universe Splitter do?
好的，那么这个“宇宙分裂器”有什么用？
It lets you do both. Like, it creates a duplicate of this universe so that in one you get to grow the beard, and in the other you shave it off.
它让你两者兼得。比如，它创造了这个宇宙的副本，在一个宇宙里你留胡子，在另一个宇宙里你把它刮掉。
Wait, that's what we're going to do?
等等，这就是我们要做的吗？
Yeah.
是的。
For pretend or for real?
是假装的，还是真的？
No, no, for real, maybe. This is a thing. It's called the many-worlds interpretation of quantum mechanics. And there are a lot of really smart physicists who think this is probably what's happening.
不，不，可能是真的。这是一件事。它被称为量子力学的多世界诠释。有很多非常聪明的物理学家认为这很可能正在发生。
OK, so how does this work? Like, what do I do next?
好的，那这怎么运作？我下一步该做什么？
All right, so there are two boxes there?
好了，那里有两个框，对吧？
Yeah. In one box it says, In one universe, I will now.
是的。其中一个框写着：“在其中一个宇宙中，我现在将……”
OK, so put, shave off beard tonight.
好，那就写：今晚刮掉胡子。
Hold on-- shave off beard tonight. OK, and then the other box is labeled, In the other universe. In the other one, I will now--
等等——今晚刮掉胡子。好的，然后另一个框标记为：“在另一个宇宙中”。在另一个宇宙里，我现在将……
Put keep beard.
写：保留胡子。
Keep beard.
保留胡子。
OK. And then what's below it?
好的。那下面是什么？
And then below it there's like a button with like, an atom drawn on it.
下面有一个像按钮的东西，上面画着一个原子。
[LAUGHS] Yeah.
[笑] 是的。
Like an atom like you would draw it in a 1950s cartoon.
就像你在 1950 年代的卡通片里画的那种原子。
Yeah, that's like the aesthetic of the whole thing. It's like an old piece of scientific equipment.
是的，那就是整个东西的美学。它就像一件旧的科学仪器。
So what does it do when you push the button?
那你按下按钮它会做什么？
So if you push the button, it sends a signal to a fancy piece of scientific equipment at the University of Geneva in Switzerland. And the equipment these days can be tiny, like a little box you can hold in your hand. And it does the following. It takes a single particle of light, a photon, it sends it at a kind of mirror that can make the photon either go left or right. You can think of it that way.
如果你按下按钮，它会向位于瑞士日内瓦大学的一台精密科学设备发送信号。如今这台设备可以做得很小，就像你可以拿在手里的小盒子一样。它做的事情如下：它取一个单一的光粒子，一个光子，把它发送到一个可以使光子向左或向右偏转的镜子上。你可以这样想。
Like at random it'll go either left or right?
就像随机地它会向左或向右？
Well, according to the laws of quantum mechanics, which govern very small things, it actually goes both. It's not that we don't know. It actually goes left and right at the same time.
嗯，根据支配微小事物的量子力学定律，它实际上是向两个方向都去了。不是我们不知道，它实际上同时向左和向右去了。
OK.
好的。
So that's super weird, right? But that is actually true, and demonstrated, and like we've known that since the '20s.
所以这超级奇怪，对吧？但这确实是真的，而且经过了验证，我们从 20 年代起就知道这一点了。
OK. So then what happens in this device in Geneva?
好的。那么这个日内瓦的设备里发生了什么？
Yeah, so the device fires a photon which can go left or right. And then the device looks to see, well, where did it go? And we know the particle's in both places, right? But when the machine looks, it only finds it in one place. It shows it went either left or right, which doesn't make sense, right? Because we know from the math that the particle did go to both places. So why did we only see it in one of those places?
是的，设备发射一个可以向左或向右的光子。然后设备观察它去了哪里。我们知道粒子在两个地方，对吧？但当机器观察时，它只在其中一个地方找到了它。它显示它要么向左要么向右，这说不通，对吧？因为我们从数学上知道粒子确实去了两个地方。那么为什么我们只在其中一个地方看到了它？
And what's the answer?
答案是什么？
All right, so one of the answers is that the photon is in both places, left and right, but just in different universes.
好吧，其中一个答案是光子确实在两个地方，左边和右边，只是在不同的宇宙里。
Wait. So you're saying that when you shoot the photon into the mirror, it actually creates an entire duplicate of our universe. And in one of those universes, the photon is on the left, and the other it is on the right?
等等。你是说当你把光子射入镜子时，它实际上创造了一个我们宇宙的完整副本？在一个宇宙里光子在左边，在另一个宇宙里它在右边？
Yes. It both went left and right. Those are just in different universes. The math of it makes a lot of-- the math of it is very, like, streamlined and simple. I remember the day I saw it in class, and I was like, oh, my god. Maybe it's true.
是的。它既向左又向右。它们只是在不同的宇宙里。它的数学逻辑非常有……它的数学非常精简且简单。我记得我在课堂上看到它的时候，我当时想，天哪。也许这是真的。
Yeah.
是的。
So those boxes you filled out on the app--
那么你在应用里填写的那些框——
You mean the box where I typed in "shave off beard tonight", and the box where I typed in, keep beard?
你是说我输入“今晚刮掉胡子”的那个框，还有我输入“保留胡子”的那个框？
Right, right. So it'll basically choose one of those boxes if the photon goes left, and the other box if the photon goes right.
对，对。所以它基本上会选择其中一个框，如果光子向左；选择另一个框，如果光子向右。
OK, got it.
好的，懂了。
You have to do what it says.
你必须照它说的做。
You mean I have to keep the beard or shave off the beard like it tells me?
你是说我必须保留胡子或刮掉胡子，按照它告诉我的那样？
Yeah. Yeah, because when you press that button, you're going to get back one answer. But there's going to be a duplicate universe in which there is a duplicate you sitting in a duplicate studio and a duplicate me and you holding a duplicate phone in exactly the same way. The only difference is that that phone comes back with the other answer.
是的。是的，因为当你按下那个按钮时，你会得到一个结果。但会有一个副本宇宙，里面有一个副本“你”坐在一个副本录音棚里，有一个副本“我”，而且你以同样的方式拿着一部副本手机。唯一的区别是那部手机显示的是另一个结果。
And then that version of me will do whatever it says on the phone?
然后那个版本的我会做手机上显示的任何事情？
We know that other guy. We trust him. He's going to go do the other.
我们认识那个人。我们信任他。他会去执行另一个选项。
OK, I think I understand all this. Let's go ahead.
好的，我想我明白了。我们开始吧。
Do you want to press the button?
你想按那个按钮吗？
Yeah, go ahead. Push it.
是的，开始吧。按下去。
[LAUGHS] I do feel weird about it. I feel weird. I know it's crazy. I feel weird.
[笑] 我对此确实感觉很奇怪。我觉得很奇怪。我知道这很疯狂。我觉得很奇怪。
You literally just put your finger right up to the button and pulled it away in fear.
你刚才真的把手指放到按钮前，又因为恐惧缩了回去。
All right, here it goes-- the split universe.
好了，这就是它了——分裂的宇宙。
[BEEP]
[哔]
OK, it says, Input valid. Internet contacted. Geneva online. Device ready. Photon emitted. Quantum event.
好的，它显示：输入有效。已联系互联网。日内瓦在线。设备就绪。光子已发射。量子事件。
[ROCKET BLASTING]
[火箭发射声]
Your universe has just split. You're in the universe in which you should keep beard. And right now in the other universe, the other you is being told to shave off beard tonight.
你的宇宙刚刚分裂了。你处在应该保留胡子的宇宙中。而在另一个宇宙里，另一个你正被告知今晚要刮掉胡子。
So after that, I kept the beard that night. And friends at New Year's parties asked me about it. And if the universe did in fact split, the other version of me in the other universe must have had different conversations. Maybe for instance somebody gave him a great idea for a show today that, in that universe, instead of airing this show, in that universe you're hearing a totally different theme.
所以在那之后，那天晚上我留下了胡子。新年派对上的朋友们问我这件事。如果宇宙确实分裂了，另一个宇宙里的另一个版本的我一定进行过不同的对话。也许有人给了他一个很棒的节目点子，以至于在那个宇宙里，代替播出这个节目，你在那个宇宙听到的完全是另一个主题。
And David, just to be sure I'm understanding this, you're saying this isn't a metaphor. You're saying there are scientists who really believe that a second universe gets created?
大卫，为了确保我理解正确，你是说这不仅仅是个比喻。你是说有科学家真的相信一个新的宇宙被创造出来了？
Yeah, for sure. I mean, I think it's not most physicists. And there are some who think it's ridiculous, for sure. But there are some would take it very seriously.
是的，肯定的。我的意思是，我不认为这是大多数物理学家的观点。确实有一些人认为这很荒谬。但也有一些人非常认真地对待它。
OK, where is this alternate universe that we're creating?
好的，我们创造的这个替代宇宙在哪里？
Yeah, I don't really even know how to think about this. But if this is true, the universe is duplicating itself all the time. It's like a fundamental thing about existence.
是的，我甚至不知道该怎么去思考它。但如果这是真的，宇宙一直在自我复制。这就像是关于存在的一个基本事实。
Well, today on our program, in a universe that may be duplicating itself all the time, we have people who have become entranced by the idea of a parallel universe out there where things are different. In one of those stories, things are better in the alternate world in one crucial way. In another story, two parallel worlds overlap. In another, a woman tries to visit-- she actually tries to go to the parallel universe. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
好了，今天在我们的节目里，在一个可能一直在自我复制的宇宙中，我们有一些被平行宇宙的想法所吸引的人，在那里事物是不同的。在其中一个故事里，替代世界在某个关键方面要更好。在另一个故事里，两个平行世界重叠了。在另一个故事里，一个女人试图去访问——她真的试图进入那个平行宇宙。来自芝加哥 WBEZ，这是《美国生活》（This American Life）。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。请继续收听。
Act 1, Dreams From My Father. So I was e-mailing with a fiction writer that we have on our show sometimes, Etgar Keret, about today's theme. And he told me that his father used to spend a lot of time imagining worlds like we're talking about in today's program-- parallel worlds to ours that are almost the same as our world, but not quite. And he said his father did this starting during World War II. His father was 14, living in Poland-- he was Jewish-- when the Germans invaded and started sending Jews to the concentration camps.
第一幕，《我父亲的梦》。我曾和节目里常客、小说家埃特加·凯雷特（Etgar Keret）就今天的主题通过邮件交流。他告诉我，他的父亲以前常花很多时间想象我们今天节目里说的这种世界——那些与我们平行、几乎一样但又不完全一样的世界。他说他父亲从二战时期就开始这么做了。他父亲当时 14 岁，住在波兰——他是犹太人——当德国人入侵并开始把犹太人送往集中营时。
During the Second World War, him and his parents, they hid in a hole in the ground that they dug for 620 days. So he had a lot of spare time.
二战期间，他和他的父母躲在他们挖的一个地洞里，躲了 620 天。所以他有很多空余时间。
And when he was there, he would imagine all kinds of things. He would imagine a world in which the Nazis didn't exist, or in which he wasn't a Jew, or in which people just in general didn't kill each other, you know? And this kind of thing was something that he associated with being a child. Then he kind of felt that it interested him as a child, then I will probably like it too.
当他在那里时，他会想象各种各样的事情。他会想象一个纳粹不存在的世界，或者一个他不是犹太人的世界，或者一个人们总的来说不会互相残杀的世界，你知道吗？这种想法是他与童年联系在一起的。他觉得童年时这让他很感兴趣，所以我也可能会喜欢它。
Back during the war, his father couldn't leave that hole for almost two years. The Nazi headquarters was right there near the hole on the same property. A Christian farmer in his 80s would bring them food and haul out buckets of urine. They couldn't even talk a lot of the time. Etgar imagines it was like two years of meditation.
战争期间，他父亲几乎有两年不能离开那个洞。纳粹指挥部就在洞附近的同一处房产里。一位 80 多岁的基督教农夫会给他们送食物，并把装尿的桶运出去。他们很多时候甚至无法说话。埃特加想象这就像两年的冥想。
My father, the way that he would talk about his time in the hole, he would say that he would sleep, and then he would wake up, and then he would ask his father if the war was over. And his father would say no, so he would go and sleep some more. That's the way he would tell it to me. I think it's that kind of-- the softcore version.
我父亲谈论他在洞里的时光时，他会说他会睡觉，然后醒来，然后问他父亲战争是否结束了。他父亲会说没有，于是他又会继续睡。他就是这样告诉我的。我想这就是那种……轻量级版本。
And was it like, when you say a hole, could they even stand up?
当你说是“洞”时，他们甚至能站起来吗？
No. They couldn't stand in it, and they couldn't even lie down in it. They had to sit in it. And when the Russians liberated the town and they were brought out, they had to be carried out because their muscles were so cramped that, by the time of the end of the war, they couldn't move them.
不能。他们站不起来，甚至躺不下。他们必须坐在里面。当俄国人解放那个小镇，他们被带出来时，他们必须被抬出来，因为他们的肌肉在战争结束时已经蜷缩得太厉害，无法活动了。
Oh, my god. So basically they're in this hole, and they're sitting there?
天哪。所以基本上他们一直呆在这个洞里，坐在那里？
Yes. And you know, it's like it's very, very cold, you know? It's way beyond freezing. And you don't have food. And you hear voices in German, and you know that you can easily be killed. And you close your eyes, and you think of another universe.
是的。而且你知道，那里非常非常冷，你知道吗？远低于冰点。你没有食物。你听到德语的声音，你知道你很容易被杀掉。你闭上眼睛，然后想着另一个宇宙。
Etgar's written lots of fiction that imagines parallel worlds of various kinds. And when I asked him if he wanted to do something for today's show, he wrote this story-- a true story that starts when he was a kid.
埃特加写了很多想象各种平行世界的小说。当我问他是否愿意为今天的节目做点什么时，他写了这个故事——一个从他小时候开始的真实故事。
When I was six years old, my dad worked at a pool snack bar not far from one of Tel Aviv's beaches. Every day at 5:30 in the morning he'd leave home for the pool, swim 2 kilometers, shower in the locker room, and get to work. He wouldn't get home till 9:00 at night. 14 hours a day, 7 days a week unloading boxes of soft drinks, dressing toasted sandwiches, brewing coffee in gleaming glasses at the pool snack bar up by the beach.
我六岁时，我爸爸在离特拉维夫海滩不远的一个游泳池小吃吧工作。每天早上 5 点半，他就会离家去泳池，游 2 公里，在更衣室冲个澡，然后开始工作。他直到晚上 9 点才到家。每天 14 小时，每周 7 天，在海滩边的泳池小吃吧卸软饮料箱、准备吐司三明治、用闪闪发光的杯子煮咖啡。
Years later, Dad always said those were the best days of his life, fondly remembering how the salty air blowing in from the sea would mix in his lungs with the smell of the coffee and the imported cigarettes he used to sell at the bar. Coffee, cigarettes, and the sea were always my father's three favorite things.
多年后，爸爸总说那是他一生中最美好的日子，深情地回忆着海风吹进肺里，混合着咖啡和他在吧台卖的进口香烟的味道。咖啡、香烟和大海，一直是我父亲最喜欢的三样东西。
For me, those days were not quite as happy. When Dad came back from work, I was already in bed. And other than Saturdays when I'd go off to visit him at the pool with my mom, I never saw him at all. Not that I was bitter about this. Six-year-old children can't really imagine a different world for themselves, one where their father had more time for them. They accept reality as it is. And yet, I missed him dearly.
对我来说，那些日子并不那么快乐。当爸爸下班回来，我已经睡了。除了周六我会跟妈妈去泳池看他，我几乎见不到他。并不是我对这点感到痛苦。六岁的孩子无法真正想象一个属于他们的不同世界，一个父亲有更多时间陪伴他们的世界。他们接受现实本来如此。然而，我非常想念他。
Seeing this, my mother suggested I go with him every morning to the pool, have a swim together, and take a cab to school from there. I don't remember anything of those morning swims, but the car rides with Dad are crystal clear.
看到这点，我母亲建议我每天早上和他一起去泳池，一起游泳，然后从那里坐出租车去学校。我不记得那些晨泳的任何细节，但和爸爸一起的车程却历历在目。
It's still dark as we sit in our Silver Peugeot 504, the windows rolled down, Dad smoking Kent 100s and describing parallel universes that exist at this very moment in other dimensions-- universes where everything is precisely identical to ours-- same road, same traffic light, same cigarette in the corner of Dad's mouth-- all except for one tiny difference. And this difference Dad would change every morning, changing the one detail in the parallel universe that differed from ours.
天还是黑的，我们坐在银色的标致 504 里，车窗摇下，爸爸抽着健牌（Kent 100s）香烟，描述着此时此刻在其他维度中存在的平行宇宙——在那儿，一切都与我们完全相同——相同的道路、相同的交通灯、爸爸嘴角的同一支香烟——除了一个细微的差别。而这个差别，爸爸每天早上都会改变，在那个与我们不同的平行宇宙中改变这一个细节。
Here we are in the parallel universe waiting at the exact same intersection for the light to change. Only in this universe, instead of a Silver Peugeot, we are riding a dragon. And here's another one where under my faded sweatpants hide gills which allow me to breathe under water like a fish.
我们正处于平行宇宙，在完全相同的十字路口等待变灯。只是在这个宇宙里，我们骑的是龙，而不是银色标致。还有另一个宇宙，在我的褪色运动裤下隐藏着鱼鳃，让我像鱼一样可以在水下呼吸。
When I was nine, my father got a new job. He no longer had to get up so early in the morning. And in the evenings, we'd all have dinner together and watch the nightly news. I was 22 by the time I moved out of my parents' house, but I still made sure to visit them at least twice a week. And on Saturdays, I'd swim with Dad at the pool where he once worked.
我九岁时，父亲换了份新工作。他不再需要那么早起床了。晚上，我们全家会一起吃晚餐，看夜间新闻。我搬出父母家时已经 22 岁了，但我仍然确保每周至少去看望他们两次。周六，我会和爸爸在他曾经工作的泳池游泳。
When I was 43, my father was diagnosed with cancer. It was tongue cancer, the result of 50 years of smoking. By the time the doctors caught on, it was at an advanced stage. And though we never spoke a word about it, it was obvious to us both that soon he was going to die.
我 43 岁时，父亲被诊断出患有癌症。是舌癌，吸了 50 年烟的结果。当医生发现时，已经是晚期了。虽然我们从没提起过，但我们都知道他很快就要去世了。
On Mondays, I take him in for his physical therapy. And as we sat in the waiting room to see the physical therapist with the British accent, my father sometimes still talked about parallel universes where everything was exactly the same as ours, save for one difference-- say, that dogs could speak, or that people could read minds, or that the sky was purple. And when the milk white clouds floated across it, they looked tasty enough to eat.
周一，我带他去做物理治疗。当我们在候诊室等那位有英国口音的物理治疗师时，父亲偶尔还会谈论那些平行宇宙，那里的一切都和我们的一样，只是有一个不同——比如，狗会说话，或者人们会读心术，或者天空是紫色的。当乳白色的云朵飘过时，它们看起来美味得足以吞下。
At the end of every session, the physical therapist would show me how to hold my father's arm when we walked together and what I should do in case he lost his balance. On our way home as we approached the corner of King Solomon and Arlozorov, Dad would always stop. "Do you smell that?" he'd say, and point to the new cafe at the corner. "Just by the smell of it, I can tell you that's the best coffee in town."
每次疗程结束时，物理治疗师都会教我如何在我们一起走路时扶着父亲的胳膊，以及万一他失去平衡我该怎么做。在回家的路上，当我们走近所罗门王和阿洛佐罗夫街的转角，爸爸总是会停下来。“你闻到了吗？”他会说，指向街角的新咖啡馆。“光凭闻味道，我就知道那是城里最好的咖啡。”
At this stage of his illness, the tongue cancer was so advanced my father could no longer eat or drink. Instead, he got all his food and liquids through a clear plastic tube straight to his stomach. On one of these Mondays after physical therapy while walking by the corner cafe on King Solomon and Arlozorov, my father, instead of just posing to praise the place as usual, suggested we actually go in for a cup of coffee.
在疾病的这个阶段，舌癌已经非常严重，父亲再也无法进食或喝水了。相反，他通过一根穿过喉咙直接进入胃部的透明塑料管获取所有食物和液体。在物理治疗后的一个周一，当我们走过所罗门王和阿洛佐罗夫街的那个街角咖啡馆时，父亲没有像往常那样停下来称赞那家店，而是建议我们进去喝杯咖啡。
"Dad," I said after a moment's hesitation, "you can't drink anything. The tumor is blocking your esophagus." "I know," he said and patted me on the back, "but you can."
“爸爸，”我迟疑了片刻后说，“你不能喝任何东西。肿瘤堵住了你的食道。”“我知道，”他说，拍了拍我的背，“但你可以。”
We sat at a corner table on the sidewalk. I ordered a latte and a glass of water from the pretty waitress. And when she asked my father what he'd like, he asked for a double espresso. I stared at him, confused, and he smiled and shrugged. The waitress noticed Dad's guilty smile and gave me a questioning look. Not knowing what to say, I ordered an oatmeal cookie.
我们在人行道上的角落桌子坐下。我向那个漂亮的女招待点了一杯拿铁和一杯水。当她问父亲想要什么时，他点了一杯双份浓缩咖啡。我困惑地盯着他，他微笑着耸了耸肩。女招待注意到了爸爸那愧疚的微笑，给了我一个疑问的眼神。不知该说什么，我点了一块燕麦饼干。
Until the coffee arrived, we sat in silence. I wanted to ask my father why he'd ordered the coffee at all and if it had anything to do with the waitress being pretty, but I said nothing. Dad pulled a cigarette pack out of his shirt pocket and a lighter he had stored in his glasses case and set them both down on the table. We waited.
在咖啡端上来之前，我们沉默地坐着。我想问父亲为什么点咖啡，是不是因为女招待很漂亮，但我没开口。爸爸从衬衫口袋里掏出一包香烟，又从眼镜盒里拿出打火机，放在桌上。我们等待着。
A few minutes later, the waitress returned with our order. She placed it on the table-- a latte, a glass of water, and a cookie in front of me, and a double espresso in front of Dad. Aromatic steam rose from my coffee. I wanted to drink it. But doing that in Dad's face seemed unfair, so I just kept staring at it.
几分钟后，女招待带着我们的点单回来了。她把咖啡放在桌上——我面前是一杯拿铁、一杯水和一块饼干，爸爸面前是一杯双份浓缩咖啡。我杯里的咖啡冒着芳香的蒸汽。我很想喝。但在爸爸面前喝似乎不太公平，所以我只是盯着它。
When out of the corner of my eye, I saw my father quickly snatch the double espresso off the table and gulp it down in one sip. It was impossible. I knew it was impossible. After all, I was there in the room when the oncologists showed me and my mother the X-ray with the tumor resting above the blocked esophagus like a scoop of vanilla ice cream on a waffle cone.
就在这时，我眼角余光看到父亲迅速从桌上抓起双份浓缩咖啡，一口气喝了下去。这不可能。我知道这不可能。毕竟，当肿瘤科医生带我和母亲看X光片时，我就在现场，那个肿瘤像蛋卷冰淇淋顶部的香草球一样压在堵塞的食道上方。
My father, she said then, could never drink again. And here we were sitting together on a pleasant summer day at this hipster cafe, me still staring at my steaming cup of coffee, and him by my side, smiling after killing off his double espresso.
她说，我父亲再也不能喝任何东西了。然而现在，在一个惬意的夏日午后，我们坐在这家时髦的咖啡馆里，我还盯着冒着热气的咖啡，而他坐在我身边，喝掉双份浓缩咖啡后微笑着。
And for a moment there, I thought maybe we were in a parallel universe. Maybe he told me enough stories ever since I was a little boy to tear open a hole in the aching heart of our universe through which we were sucked into a parallel one, identical to our own in every way save for one exception. In this universe, my dad could drink and eat as much as he liked, and he was not about to die in just a few months.
有一瞬间，我以为我们可能身处平行宇宙。也许他从我小时候起就给我讲了足够多的故事，在宇宙那令人心碎的空洞上撕开了一个口子，让我们被吸进了一个平行宇宙，那个宇宙与我们原本的宇宙在各方面都一模一样，除了一个例外。在这个宇宙里，爸爸可以随心所欲地吃喝，而且他不会在几个月内死去。
The piping hot coffee slid down my father's windpipe and into his lungs. When it got there, Dad started to choke. He stood up and grabbed his throat with both hands. The wet wheezing noises he made were horrific-- the sound of a man whose lungs are flooded with hot coffee. A bespectacled man from the table next to us leaped up and asked my father if he needed any help.
滚烫的咖啡滑进了父亲的气管，进入了他的肺部。到了那里，爸爸开始窒息。他站起来，双手抓住喉咙。他发出的潮湿的喘息声太可怕了——那是一个肺部被热咖啡淹没的男人的声音。坐在我们隔壁桌的一位戴眼镜的男士跳了起来，问我父亲是否需要帮助。
I just sat there paralyzed. The parallel universe I had shared with my father moments ago had vanished, dropping me back into a far worse universe. A few more seconds of gargling followed, after which Dad leaned over and coughed up, evacuating all the fine Italian espresso that had filled his lungs.
我只是呆坐在那里。刚才我和父亲共享的那个平行宇宙消失了，把我丢回了一个更糟糕的宇宙中。又持续了几秒钟的喉咙咕噜声，接着爸爸弯下腰咳嗽起来，吐出了所有填充在他肺里的意式浓缩咖啡。
When he was done, he sat up in his chair as if nothing had happened, inches away from the puddle of coffee and phlegm, and lit himself a cigarette. People at the tables around us kept staring at him. "What did I tell you?" He smiled at me and exhaled smoke from his nostrils. "The best coffee in town."
咳完后，他坐在椅子上，就好像什么都没发生过一样，离那一滩咖啡和痰液只有几英寸远，然后点了一根烟。周围桌子的人一直盯着他看。“我跟你说什么来着？”他向我微笑，从鼻孔里呼出烟雾。“城里最好的咖啡。”
Etgar Keret. He's the author of many books. He writes about his dad and the rest of his family in stories a lot like this one-- emotional fables that happen to be true-- in his book, The Seven Good Years.
埃特加·凯雷特。他是许多书的作者。他在他的书《七个好年头》（The Seven Good Years）里写了很多关于他父亲和他家人的故事，就像这个故事一样——那些恰好是真实发生的情感寓言。
Act 2, Sorry, Not Sorry. So it's kind of grim to say this, but the moon landing-- that story of American triumph-- it could've gone in another way. In some other storyline from the multiverse, Neil Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin, they land on the moon, they walk around, it's great. But then there's a problem, and they cannot take off to come home. NASA thought this was the most dangerous moment in the mission, the most likely spot it could fail.
第二幕，《抱歉，不是真抱歉》。说这些话有点阴郁，但登月——那个关于美国胜利的故事——它本可能走向另一个结局。在多元宇宙的某个其他情节线里，尼尔·阿姆斯特朗和巴兹·奥尔德林登上了月球，四处走动，一切都很棒。但后来出了问题，他们无法起飞回家。NASA 认为这是任务中最危险的时刻，最有可能失败的地方。
One of President Richard Nixon's speechwriters, William Safire, actually prepared a statement to be read in case that was the way the story went. At the top of the page in all caps it read, "In the event of moon disaster,"-- first line of the speech-- "fate has ordained that the men who went to the moon to explore it in peace will stay on the moon to rest in peace." Pretty good.
理查德·尼克松总统的一位演讲稿撰稿人威廉·萨菲尔（William Safire）实际上准备了一份声明，以备故事那样发展时诵读。在页面顶部全是大写字母写着：“在登月灾难发生的情况下”——演讲的第一行——“命运注定那些去月球和平探索的人将留在月球安息。”挺好的。
David Kestenbaum has this next story about another presidential speech, never delivered, that also feels like it slipped into our world from a parallel universe. You can find this speech framed, hanging in the guest bathroom of a home in California. Here's David.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆有下一个故事，关于另一场从未发表的总统演讲，也让人觉得它像是从平行宇宙溜进了我们的世界。你可以发现这篇演讲被装裱起来，挂在加利福尼亚州一户人家的客用浴室里。大卫，请讲。
The speech was to be read on the night of August 17, 1998. It's in the house of Bob Shrum, because he wrote it. Shrum was a longtime Democratic political strategist, speechwriter, and getter-outer of tight spots.
这篇演讲本应在 1998 年 8 月 17 日晚上发表。它现在在鲍勃·舒姆（Bob Shrum）家里，因为是他写的。舒姆是一位资深的民主党政治策略师、演讲稿撰稿人，也是解决棘手问题的能手。
Are you personally good at apologizing?
你个人擅长道歉吗？
Oh, I've had to apologize so many times for so many things-- sure.
噢，我因为各种各样的事情道过歉太多次了——当然。
What's the most recent thing you apologized for?
你最近一次道歉是因为什么？
Having a fight with my wife about what we were giving various people as Christmas gifts.
和妻子因为我们给不同人送什么圣诞礼物而吵架。
This story is about an apology he wrote for a much bigger audience. That August, 1998, Shrum was on vacation in Idaho staying with some friends, and the phone rang.
这个故事是关于他为更大规模的受众写的道歉词。1998 年 8 月，舒姆正在爱达荷州度假，和一些朋友在一起，电话响了。
Well, I didn't have a cell phone then, so somehow or other-- oh, my office called me and said Mark was trying to reach me.
好吧，当时我没有手机，所以不知怎么的——噢，我的办公室打电话给我说马克正在试图联系我。
Mark is Mark Penn, who at the time was conducting polls and advising the President of the United States, who at the time was Bill Clinton, who at the time was in a lot of hot water.
马克是指马克·潘（Mark Penn），他当时正在为时任美国总统比尔·克林顿进行民调并提供咨询，总统当时陷入了很大的麻烦中。
Impeachment might very well be an option-- tampering with witnesses, obstruction of justice are very, very serious charges.
弹劾很可能是一个选择——篡改证人、妨碍司法是非常非常严重的指控。
A moment when one political party said there were very valid high crimes and misdemeanors, and the other party said that's ridiculous political posturing. Anyway, there had been stories in the press for months at this point that Clinton might have had an affair with an intern, Monica Lewinsky. Clinton denied it, though, under oath in a civil case, and famously on television.
那是政党一方表示确实存在严重的“重罪和轻罪”，而另一方表示那是荒谬的政治作秀的时刻。不管怎样，媒体已经报道好几个月了，克林顿可能和实习生莫妮卡·莱温斯基有染。但克林顿在民事案件中宣誓作证时，以及在电视上著名地否认了这一点。
[CAMERAS CLICKING]
[相机快门声]
But I want to say one thing to the American people. I want you to listen to me. I'm going to say this again. I did not have sexual relations with that woman, Miss Lewinsky.
但我只想对美国人民说一件事。我要你们听我说。我要再说一遍。我没有和那个女人，莱温斯基小姐，发生过性关系。
But there was the dress with Clinton's DNA on it and recorded phone calls between Monica Lewinsky and a co-worker talking about the affair. At the time Bob Shrum got the call, President Clinton was finally going to have to testify before independent counsel Ken Starr's grand jury. He would have to own up to the affair, and then afterwards say something to the nation. But what?
但那件带有克林顿 DNA 的裙子存在，还有莫妮卡·莱温斯基和一个同事谈论这段婚外情的录音电话。鲍勃·舒姆接到电话时，克林顿总统终于要到独立检察官肯·斯塔尔（Ken Starr）的大陪审团前作证了。他必须承认这段恋情，然后事后对全国说些什么。但说什么呢？
That was what the phone call was about. Shrum called Mark Penn back, who asked if he would take a shot at writing a speech for the president to be delivered on TV just after he gave his grand jury testimony. It would be the president's chance to frame the whole thing, maybe finally put it away and prevent the Republicans from starting impeachment proceedings. The country would be watching. Bob Shrum said OK. He hung up the phone and told his wife and the couple they were staying with on vacation what the assignment was.
这就是那通电话的内容。舒姆回电给马克·潘，马克问他是否愿意试着写一篇总统演讲，在总统大陪审团作证后立即在电视上发表。这将是总统界定整个事件、也许最终平息它并阻止共和党开始弹劾程序的机会。全国都会观看。鲍勃·舒姆说好。他挂断电话，告诉了他的妻子和他们一起度假的那对夫妇这项任务。
One of the people there said, this better be good.
其中一人说，这最好得写好。
Meaning you better do a good job?
意思是说你最好表现出色？
Yes.
是的。
Yeah.
So I sat at the dining room table and I wrote in longhand on a yellow pad, which is how I've always written. I drafted it.
所以我就坐在餐桌前，用黄色的记事本手写，那是我一直以来的写作方式。我起草了它。
What he wrote was a straight up, direct apology.
他写的是一个直截了当的道歉。
Do you have it there with you?
你带在身边了吗？
It's on the-- well, actually, I can go get it. You want to hold on for a second?
它在——嗯，事实上，我可以去取。你想等一下吗？
Shrum went to go get it from where it was hanging in what he calls the guest powder room. And to be clear, there's other political memorabilia in there. It's a speech he's proud of.
舒姆去取演讲稿了，它挂在他所谓的客用盥洗室里。要清楚，那里还有其他政治纪念品。这是他引以为豪的一篇演讲。
Can you read the speech for me?
你能为我读一下这篇演讲吗？
Yeah. It's not very long, so I will.
好的。不太长，所以我读一下。
"My fellow Americans, no one who is not in my position can understand fully the remorse I feel today. Since I was very young, I have had a profound reverence for this office I hold. I've been honored that you, the people, have entrusted it to me. I am proud of what we have accomplished together.
“我的美国同胞们，没有身处我这个位置的人，无法完全理解我今天感受到的懊悔。从我很小的时候起，我就对这个职位怀有深刻的敬畏。我很荣幸你们，人民，把它托付给我。我为我们共同取得的成就感到自豪。”
But in this case, I have fallen short of what you should expect from a president. I have failed my own religious faith and values. I have let too many people down. I take full responsibility for my actions-- for hurting my wife and daughter, for hurting Monica Lewinsky and her family, for hurting friends and staff, and for hurting the country I love. None of this ever should have happened."
“但在这种情况下，我没有达到你们对总统应有的期望。我辜负了自己的宗教信仰和价值观。我让太多人失望了。我为自己的行为负全责——伤害了我的妻子和女儿，伤害了莫妮卡·莱温斯基和她的家人，伤害了朋友和幕僚，伤害了我所热爱的国家。这一切都不应该发生。”
Then he has Clinton apologizing for misleading people about the affair. And this is how it ends.
然后他让克林顿为误导人们关于这段婚外情而道歉。结尾是这样的。
"Finally, I also want to apologize to all of you, my fellow citizens. I hope that you can find it in your heart to accept my apology. I pledge to you that I will make every effort of mind and spirit to earn your confidence again, to be worthy of this office, and to finish the work on which we have made such remarkable progress in the past six years. God bless you, and good night."
“最后，我也想向你们所有人，我的同胞们致歉。我希望你们能从心底里接受我的道歉。我向你们保证，我将竭尽心力重新赢得你们的信任，证明自己不负这个职位，并完成我们在过去六年里取得显著进展的工作。愿上帝保佑你们，晚安。”
How does it feel reading that?
读这段文字感觉如何？
I mean, I remember writing it. I thought it was the right thing for him to say. And when I hear it now, I still think it's the right thing for him to say.
我的意思是，我记得写它的经过。我认为这是他该说的正确的话。当我今天听到它时，我仍然认为这是他该说的正确的话。
It's notable that Shrum had the president apologizing to Monica Lewinsky and her family. At the time, Charles Rangel, the Democratic congressman from New York, called her, quote, "a young tramp."
值得注意的是，舒姆让总统向莫妮卡·莱温斯基及其家人道歉。当时，来自纽约的民主党国会议员查尔斯·兰格尔（Charles Rangel）称她为“年轻的流浪女”。
She was the subject of jokes on late night television. Bill Maher said, "I think Monica Lewinsky is the one who should apologize to America." No one seemed to be thinking about her as a person whose life was now a wreck. Shrum was.
她是深夜电视节目笑话的对象。比尔·马赫（Bill Maher）说：“我认为莫妮卡·莱温斯基才应该是那个向美国道歉的人。”似乎没有人把她当成一个生活已被毁掉的普通人。舒姆想到了。
Well, I mean, she was an intern, a kid in the White House. And I thought that that made every bit of sense in the world.
嗯，我的意思是，她是个实习生，白宫里的一个孩子。我认为那非常有道理。
Shrum sent the speech into the White House. And then the day arrived. Clinton gave his grand jury testimony, which was not broadcast. And that evening, the president went on TV to give his speech. Shrum sat down with the rest of the country to watch it.
舒姆把演讲稿送进了白宫。然后那一天到了。克林顿在大陪审团前作证，没有播出。那天晚上，总统上电视发表了他的演讲。舒姆和全国人民一起坐下来观看。
We were just sitting around in the living room, watching it on television.
我们当时只是坐在客厅里，在电视上看着。
And at that point are you thinking, maybe he's going to read my speech?
在那一刻，你是否在想，也许他要读我写的演讲稿了？
Sure. I thought he might very well-- Bill Clinton, who I worked with on State of the Union messages, never exactly reads what you send him. So I didn't anticipate that it would be necessarily word for word what I had sent, but I thought it might be pretty close to it. It was almost diametrically the opposite.
当然。我心想他很有可能——比尔·克林顿，我和他在国情咨文中合作过，他从来不完全照读你送给他的东西。所以我没指望它一定是逐字逐句照我送的读，但我以为可能会很接近。结果完全相反。
Good evening. This afternoon in this room, from this chair, I testified before the office of independent counsel and the grand jury. I answered their questions truthfully, including questions about my private life, questions no American citizen would ever want to answer.
晚上好。今天下午在这个房间里，从这把椅子上，我在独立检察官办公室和大陪审团前作证。我如实回答了他们的问题，包括关于我私生活的问题，任何美国公民都不愿回答的问题。
I not only remember hearing the first words, but I remember the look on his face. He was really, really angry. It's the private Bill Clinton who could get angry. And I have seen him angry, but I don't think the country had seen him angry very often.
我不但记得听到第一句话，还记得他脸上的表情。他真的非常非常生气。那是私底下的比尔·克林顿，那个会发火的人。我见过他生气，但我认为国家还没见过他这么频繁地生气。
As you know, in a deposition in January, I was asked questions about my relationship with Monica Lewinsky. While my answers were legally accurate, I did not volunteer information. Indeed, I did have a relationship with Miss Lewinsky that was not appropriate. In fact, it was wrong. It constituted a critical lapse in judgment and a personal failure on my part for which I am solely and completely responsible.
如你们所知，在 1 月的一份证词中，我被问及与莫妮卡·莱温斯基的关系。虽然我的回答在法律上是准确的，但我没有主动提供信息。事实上，我确实与莱温斯基小姐有过不恰当的关系。事实上，这是错误的。这是判断力的严重失误，是我个人的失败，我对此负全部责任。
There are moments of apology in there and what feel like honest reflection, like when he straight up admits the reasons he had been so evasive until then.
里面有道歉的时刻，也有像诚实反思的部分，比如当他直言不讳地承认直到那时他还如此回避的原因。
I can only tell you I was motivated by many factors-- first, by a desire to protect myself from the embarrassment of my own conduct.
我只能告诉你们，我受到了许多因素的驱动——首先，是为了保护自己免受自身行为尴尬的渴望。
But the overall message is not I'm sorry. I screwed up, he seems to be saying, but the real problem is the fact that I'm having to talk about this at all. It's a private family matter.
但整体信息不是“我很抱歉”。他似乎在说，我搞砸了，但真正的问题是我居然不得不谈论这个事实。这是私人的家庭事务。
It's nobody's business but ours. Even presidents have private lives.
这除了我们，不关任何人的事。即使是总统也有私生活。
He closes not by asking for forgiveness, as Shrum had advised, but by asking people to stop gawking.
他的结尾不是像舒姆建议的那样请求宽恕，而是要求人们停止围观。
And so tonight, I ask you to turn away from the spectacle of the past seven months, to repair the fabric of our national discourse, and to return our attention to all the challenges and all the promise of the next American century. Thank you for watching, and good night.
所以今晚，我要求你们不要再关注过去七个月的闹剧，修复我们国民对话的基础，并将我们的注意力转回到下一个美国世纪的所有挑战和承诺上。谢谢收看，晚安。
What do you think would have happened if instead that night he'd taken out your speech and read it?
你认为如果那天晚上他拿出你的演讲稿读了，会发生什么？
I think it would have lessened the chances that he would've been impeached.
我认为这会降低他被弹劾的机会。
Really?
真的吗？
I don't know that it would have prevented the impeachment, but I think it would have lessened the chances.
我不知道那能否阻止弹劾，但我认为那会降低概率。
It's possible his speech gets you to the same ending, just with a slightly different plot. And after all, there was a lot of momentum in Congress toward impeachment. But it's nice to contemplate a world where the leader of your country can stand up and acknowledge having made a mistake, can acknowledge reality.
也许他的演讲能带你走到同样的结局，只是情节略有不同。毕竟，国会中弹劾的呼声很高。但考虑这样一个世界是件好事：你的国家领导人能够站出来承认犯了错误，能够承认现实。
An apology really is about the truth-- laying it out so we can all live in the same world together. It's impossible to imagine that happening now. Clinton seemed closer to it at that moment, but he still couldn't do it.
道歉实际上是关于真相的——把它摆出来，这样我们才能共同生活在同一个世界里。很难想象现在还会发生这种事。克林顿在那一刻似乎离它更近一些，但他仍然做不到。
I wonder, of all the possible universes, in how many of them does Clinton say I'm sorry, you know? Not I'm sorry for what happened, or I'm sorry if people feel-- but really like I'm sorry.
我很好奇，在所有可能的宇宙中，克林顿在其中多少个宇宙说了“我抱歉”？你知道吗？不是为发生了什么感到抱歉，也不是如果人们感到什么而抱歉——而是真正意义上的“我抱歉”。
There may be a universe in which he did that. I'm just not aware of it, because I don't live in it.
也许有一个宇宙他那样做了。我只是不知道，因为我没生活在那里。
[LAUGHS] Yeah, that's not the one we live in.
[笑] 是的，那不是我们生活的那个世界。
You want to know what I think? I think it's possible there is no universe in which President Clinton reads Bob Shrum's speech. Listening to the speech Clinton did give, I kind of think he gives it in every possible universe. It was exactly how he felt.
你想知道我怎么看吗？我觉得可能根本不存在克林顿总统朗读鲍勃·舒姆演讲稿的宇宙。听着克林顿确实发表的那篇演讲，我倒觉得他在每一个可能的宇宙中都会发表那篇。那正是他的真实感受。
And the speech that you wrote, while great, was not at all how he was feeling at that moment.
而你写的演讲稿，虽然很棒，却根本不是他当时的感觉。
Obviously, the speech that I drafted did not reflect how he felt coming out of the grand jury.
显然，我草拟的演讲并没有反映他走出大陪审团时的感受。
In that sense, can you fault him?
从这个意义上讲，你能怪他吗？
I just think you want to do what fits the moment, and you want to be true to yourself. The problem was that, I think, he was true to the angry guy who had just come out of the room, you know? He was maybe not true to the person he was the next day.
我只是认为你想要做符合那一刻的事，你想忠于自己。问题是，我觉得，他忠于了那个刚走出房间的愤怒的人，你知道吗？他也许没有忠于第二天的那个人。
There are the yous in all the parallel worlds, but also the you on Thursday and the one on Friday, the one who's had some time to think, and some sleep, and a sandwich. For sure, those are different people.
在所有平行世界里都有“你”，但也有星期四的你和星期五的那个你，那个已经有时间思考、睡了个觉、吃了顿三明治的你。显然，那些是不同的人。
David Kestenbaum. In some other universe, he stayed a physicist for all of his life. In this one, he is the executive editor of our program.
大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。在某个其他宇宙里，他一生都是一名物理学家。在这一世，他是我们节目的执行编辑。
Bill Clinton, by the way, later wrote about this address to the nation that night in his biography. He does not mention Shrum's draft of the speech, but he does say that most of his advisors had counseled him to simply admit that he had made an awful mistake-- not to go out swinging. He did anyway, of course.
顺便说一句，比尔·克林顿后来在他的传记中写到了那晚向全国发表的演讲。他没有提及舒姆的演讲草稿，但他确实说大多数幕僚曾建议他仅仅承认自己犯了一个可怕的错误——而不是大动干戈。当然，他还是那样做了。
Weeks after that speech, he backtracked in front of a smaller audience at a prayer breakfast with religious leaders. He took a different tone there. He said, "I agree with those who have said that in my first statement after I testified I was not contrite enough." It was much closer to what Shrum had written. He included an apology to Monica Lewinsky and her family.
演讲几周后，他在一次宗教领袖参加的祈祷早餐会上，在较小的听众面前退了一步。他在那里采取了不同的语气。他说：“我同意那些人的说法，即我在作证后的第一次声明中不够悔恨。”那比舒姆写的内容更接近。他包括了对莫妮卡·莱温斯基及其家人的道歉。
Coming up, worried that you're living in a parallel universe where some very basic facts about your own life have been altered? That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
接下来，担心你正生活在一个关于你自己生活的一些基本事实被篡改了的平行宇宙里？请关注芝加哥公共广播，稍后回来我们的节目继续。
We've arrived at Act 3 of our show, Act 3-- Sklar-Crossed Brothers.
我们进入节目的第三幕，第三幕，《斯克拉家族的纠葛》。
So if you think about it, being an identical twin is kind of a parallel world situation. You know, you have this other version of yourself stuck in the same world as you, stuck in the same house as you. You see somebody who's just like you running around, doing things that you might not do.
如果你仔细想的话，作为同卵双胞胎有点像平行世界的情况。你知道，你有另一个版本的自己被困在同一个世界里，被困在同一个房子里。你看着一个和你一模一样的人跑来跑去，做着你可能不会做的事情。
Dana Chivvis has this next story about a mother, her twins, and a 48-year-old mystery.
达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）有下一个关于一位母亲、她的双胞胎和一个 48 年未解之谜的故事。
Annette Sklar had a lot going on in the winter of '72. In January, she delivered twin boys-- Jason first, followed by Randy 5 minutes later. Weighing 5 pounds, 2 ounces, Randy had to spend the first days of life in an incubator.
安妮特·斯克拉（Annette Sklar）在 72 年的冬天有很多事要忙。一月份，她生下了一对双胞胎男孩——杰森先出来，兰迪 5 分钟后出来。兰迪体重 5 磅 2 盎司，不得不在保温箱里度过出生后的头几天。
They lived in suburban St. Louis. Annette's husband Dick had a job at a paper company, called Tension Envelope. He worked long hours and traveled a lot. Annette was often at home alone caring for two infants-- feeding them, changing diapers, and making sure she didn't lose track of which one was which, because they looked exactly alike.
他们住在圣路易斯郊区。安妮特丈夫迪克（Dick）在一家名为“Tension Envelope”的造纸公司工作。他工作时间很长，经常出差。安妮特经常一个人在家照顾两个婴儿——喂奶、换尿布，并确保她不会记混哪一个是哪一个，因为他们长得一模一样。
Were you always scared that you might mix them up? Like from the day they were born, was that a real fear?
你是否一直害怕会把他们弄混？比如从他们出生的那天起，那是一个真实的恐惧吗？
I tried to be really careful about knowing who either had-- what outfit they were on. I knew-- I was really careful about it. So usually, we had outfits in different colors-- blue, blue Jay, and red, Randy red. And then I didn't think about it too much, once I knew it was.
我试着非常小心地确定是谁穿的什么衣服。我记得——我真的很小心。所以通常，我们有不同颜色的衣服——蓝色，蓝色的杰森（Jay），红色，兰迪（Randy）红。然后我就没太去想它，一旦我知道是谁。
OK.
好的。
[LAUGHS] That's how we did it.
[笑] 我们就是那样做的。
That's a good system.
那是个好系统。
I mean, I think I did feed them twice, one of them, and didn't feed the other one. That happens, sometimes. You did that. You did that. One of them was eating, the other one was crying a lot. And I go, why is he crying so much?
我的意思是，我想我确实喂过其中一个两次，而没喂另一个。这种情况有时会发生。你做过那样的事。你做过。其中一个在吃，另一个在不停地哭。我就问，为什么他哭得那么厉害？
She even had a back-up-- a creative redundancy she built into the safety plan for their identities. And that was diaper pins. She used blue diaper pins for Jason, and yellow ones for Randy.
她甚至有一个备选方案——她在他们的身份安全计划中建立了一个创造性的冗余。那就是尿布别针。她用蓝色别针标记杰森，黄色别针标记兰迪。
Everything went smoothly for a while. And then at six weeks, they had their first check-up. Annette dressed them in the same outfit-- a fancy number their aunt in Los Angeles had sent them. But underneath the clothes, the diaper pin system was up and running.
一切顺利了一段时间。然后在六周大的时候，他们进行了第一次检查。安妮特给他们穿上了同样的衣服——他们洛杉矶的阿姨寄给他们的一套高档货。但在衣服下面，别针系统还在运行。
At the doctor's office, a nurse took the babies out of the room. Annette can't really remember why. Maybe she needed to weigh them. And a few minutes later, the nurse came back in with the boys.
在医生办公室，护士把婴儿带出了房间。安妮特记不清原因了。也许她需要称重。几分钟后，护士带着男孩们回来了。
And she goes, oh, we have such a great surprise for you. Now we have Pampers. We're just using them for the first time. So instead of using your diapers, we used your Pampers.
她说，噢，我们有个大惊喜给你。我们现在有“帮宝适”（Pampers）。我们第一次用它们。所以代替用你们的尿布，我们用了你们的“帮宝适”。
Oh, no.
噢，不。
And then they gave me all four of their tins.
然后他们把四个别针都还给了我。
The nurse had changed the babies out of their cloth diapers and put them into disposable ones, foiling the system entirely. She handed Annette a little bag with the diaper pins in it. The boys were completely indistinguishable.
护士把婴儿的布尿布换成了纸尿裤，完全破坏了那个系统。她递给安妮特一个小袋子，里面装着尿布别针。男孩们变得完全无法区分了。
I was very upset. So they go, oh, you're going to be fine. You're fine. Of course, they go, you're fine. And we got in the car, and I was so upset the whole way home.
我非常沮丧。他们说，噢，你会没事的。你会没事的。当然，他们会说，你会没事的。我们上了车，我一路上都非常难过。
When she got home, Annette put the babies on the couch and stared at them. At six weeks old, they didn't have distinct personalities yet. They weighed the same amount. They had the same bald heads. No birthmarks.
到家后，安妮特把婴儿放在沙发上盯着他们看。六周大的时候，他们还没有个性。他们的体重一样。头都是秃的。没有胎记。
And I'm not kidding you, they looked exactly alike. And so I was thinking I was a really terrible mother.
我不骗你，他们长得一模一样。所以我当时想，我真的是个糟糕的母亲。
Oh, no.
噢，不。
Then how can I really look at this and not see my own children and not know which ones they are?
那怎么能让我看着这却看不出自己的孩子，也不知道他们是谁？
You know, she called me in a panic. And she just said, I don't know what I'm going to do. I don't know which one's which. I don't know what to do.
你知道，她惊慌失措地给我打了电话。她只是说，我不知道该怎么办。我不知道哪一个是哪个。我不知道该做什么。
This is Annette's best friend Linda Wallace-- Aunt Linda, as Jason and Randy know her. She lived in the same subdivision.
这是安妮特最好的朋友琳达·华莱士（Linda Wallace）——也就是杰森和兰迪所称的琳达阿姨。她住在同一个小区。
Did you go over there to try to help her?
你过去试着帮她了吗？
No, I didn't.
没有，我没有。
Yeah.
是的。
Because if she couldn't tell them apart, how would I be able to tell them apart?
因为如果连她都分不清，我怎么能分清呢？
Right.
对。
I mean, I couldn't tell them apart, you know? She had the pins.
我的意思是，我分不清他们，你知道吗？她有别针。
Yeah. [LAUGHS]
是的。[笑]
Were you nervous to tell Dick? Were you nervous to tell your husband?
你告诉迪克时紧张吗？你告诉丈夫时紧张吗？
Yes.
是的。
You were?
你紧张？
Yes. I was really nervous. So when he came home, and he saw them, and they were in their crib-- and so finally, I had to tell him. I go, I have to tell you what happened. And I told him. And he goes, really? He goes, oh, we'll figure it out. Let's see.
是的。我真的很紧张。所以当他回家看到他们，他们都在婴儿床上——最后，我不得不告诉他。我说，我得告诉你发生了什么。我告诉了他。他说，真的？他说，噢，我们会弄明白的。看看。
And then we were both looking at both of them right next to each other. And then of course, they had the Pampers on, and nothing. And he's going, I don't know. What do you think it is? (LAUGHING) I go, I don't know.
然后我们俩都盯着靠在一起的他们。当然，他们穿着“帮宝适”，什么也没有。他问，我不知道。你觉得是谁？（笑）我说，我不知道。
Annette was faced with a decision. She had to choose which baby was Jason and which one was Randy. She had nothing to go on but a maternal feeling, so she chose. Dick agreed with her.
安妮特面临一个决定。她必须选择哪一个是杰森，哪一个是兰迪。她没有任何依据，只有一种母亲的感觉，所以她选了。迪克同意了她的说法。
I really, always felt like I had the right person in my heart. I just said it is, and I'm not going to think about it anymore. This is my life. We know who they are, and it is who they are. And we're not going to talk about it anymore.
我真的，一直觉得我的心里有正确的人选。我只是说就是他，我不会再想了。这就是我的生活。我们知道他们是谁，就是他们是谁。我们不会再谈论它了。
Aunt Linda? Not so convinced.
琳达阿姨？不那么确信。
Do you think she got it right? Do you think Annette got it right?
你觉得她选对了吗？你觉得安妮特选对了吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You don't know?
你不知道？
I mean, I don't think she knows. She says she did, but how does she know? I mean, there's no way. They were so-- they looked so much alike, and so I'm not sure.
我的意思是，我觉得她不知道。她说她做到了，但她怎么知道？我的意思是，没可能。他们太——他们长得太像了，所以我不太确定。
Jason and Randy are 48 years old now. They're comedians. They work together. They've done cameos on different TV shows, like Curb Your Enthusiasm and Better Call Saul. And they still look exactly the same.
杰森和兰迪现在 48 岁了。他们是喜剧演员。他们在一起工作。他们曾在不同的电视剧里客串，比如《抑制热情》（Curb Your Enthusiasm）和《风骚律师》（Better Call Saul）。他们现在看起来还是一模一样。
Randy, can you describe what Jason looks like?
兰迪，你能描述一下杰森长什么样吗？
He's very good looking. Jason, he is very Semitic looking. He's got glasses. He's about 5 foot, 8 and 1/2.
他长得很好看。杰森，他看起来很像闪族人（Semitic）。他戴眼镜。身高大约 5 英尺 8 英寸半。
That's generous.
够大方的。
Somewhat athletic looking.
看起来有点运动感。
Less generous.
没那么大方。
They found out about their potentially swapped identities when they were about 12 years old, by accident. They were spending a summer weekend at the world famous Lake of the Ozarks in central Missouri with their mom and Aunt Linda and her two sons. The boys were playing while Annette and Aunt Linda talked amongst themselves. The story of the calamitous doctor's visit came up. And unbeknownst to them, Jason and Randy were in earshot, and they overheard the whole thing.
他们大约 12 岁时偶然发现了他们身份可能互换的事。他们和妈妈、琳达阿姨以及她的两个儿子在密苏里州中部的世界著名景点奥扎克湖度周末。孩子们在玩耍时，安妮特和琳达阿姨私下谈话。那个灾难性的医生之行的话题被提了起来。在他们不知情的情况下，杰森和兰迪在旁边听到了全程。
And we were just-- we hated the story.
我们当时简直——我们讨厌那个故事。
This is Jason. He sounds remarkably like Randy.
这是杰森。他的声音和兰迪惊人地像。
We were livid that this could have happened, and also that she was sharing it in sort of an offhand kind of joking way. And Linda Wallace, who is a funny woman, was making it funnier. And they were laughing about it. And we were like-- we were just very embarrassed by it and upset by it. Like, oh my god, this is an insane thing to hear, because we may not be who we are.
我们对这种事竟然会发生感到愤怒，也对她以一种随意的开玩笑方式分享它感到生气。琳达·华莱士，一个风趣的女人，把故事讲得更有趣了。她们在笑。我们当时觉得——我们为它感到非常尴尬和难过。就像，天哪，听到这个太疯狂了，因为我们可能根本不是我们自己。
What pissed you off about it? What was so upsetting about it?
什么事让你感到愤怒？什么事让你那么难过？
I think that it just was we were just sensitive, I think, to being confused. And again, it was this narrative that kind of went through our lives, as we wanted to be individuals and we wanted to be seen as individuals. And then here's this thing that happened where we could be so easily confused.
我想我们只是很敏感，我觉得，对被搞混很敏感。同样，它是那种贯穿我们生活的叙事，我们想成为独立个体，希望被视为独立个体。然后发生了这件事，我们竟然可以这么轻易地被混淆。
For identical twins-- two people who are constantly being mistaken for one another, who try really hard to make it clear that they're unique individuals-- this was a big deal. Randy was the most upset.
对于同卵双胞胎——这两个人经常被认错，并且努力去明确他们是独特的个体——这是一件大事。兰迪是最难过的。
He goes, why can't you go to the policemen? I think Randy really wanted me to go there. We were talking all the way to the car.
他说，为什么不能去找警察？我想兰迪真的希望我去。我们在去车的路上一直在谈论这个。
Not that an actual crime had been committed, just a crime against their dignity. But for some reason, Randy figured the police were the ones who could sort it out. But Annette did not go to the police. And the name confusion did not get sorted out, it remained a mystery in Jason and Randy's lives.
并不是说真的发生了什么罪行，只是对他们尊严的一种冒犯。但不知何故，兰迪认为警察是可以解决问题的人。但安妮特没有报警。名字的混淆并没有被解决，它成了杰森和兰迪生活中的一个谜。
The couple times that it was brought up throughout their years, if somebody said something about it, they would go, I don't want to hear about it. Don't bring it up again.
多年来只要提到过几次，如果有人提起它，他们就会说，我不想听。别再提了。
Wow. I had no idea it was that painful for them.
哇。我不知道这对他们来说那么痛苦。
I mean, it was a joke between Annette and I that I'm not sure was a joke between all of us, because they were very sensitive about it.
我的意思是，那曾是安妮特和我之间的一个笑话，但我不敢说那是我们所有人的笑话，因为他们对此非常敏感。
Just the simple fact of the matter that for countless times in our lives, someone has said to me, Jason? And I'm like, nope, I'm Randy.
就是生活中有无数次，有人对我说，“杰森？”而我会说，“不，我是兰迪。”
Right.
对。
You know? Like, that that's happened so many times in my life. If that's not true, there is--
你知道吗？那种事在我生命中发生了太多次。如果这不是真的，这里有——
You have to go back to every single one of those people and apologize.
你必须回去向所有那些人道歉。
--and apologize. No, but there's a notion that you've been living a little bit of a lie. It's a tiny lie, but it's not your lie.
——去道歉。不，但有一种观念是，你一直在过着一种谎言。这是一个微小的谎言，但它不是你的谎言。
Not your lie.
不是你的谎言。
It's not your lie, and it's not your fault. But still, that's unsettling in a weird way, to me. That's just weird that for all this time I had it wrong.
它不是你的谎言，也不是你的错。但即便如此，那依然让我感到不安，以一种奇怪的方式。这只是很奇怪，因为这么长时间以来我一直都错了。
If they were switched, then they have to re-imagine something that's so foundational nobody ever thinks about it-- their birth. Who's older? Who was in the incubator? Like Randy says, it's weird. It doesn't really make a difference, but also somehow it does. And not knowing what the truth is, that's even more unnerving.
如果他们确实被换了，那么他们必须重新想象一些非常基础的东西，没人会想到它——他们的出生。谁大？谁在保温箱里？就像兰迪说的，这很奇怪。它并没有真正带来什么不同，但以某种方式它又很重要。而不知道真相是什么，这更让人心烦意乱。
It turns out there was one way to figure it out. Sometime around the age of 40-- Randy can't remember exactly when-- the topic of their potentially swapped identities came up. And they were like, why haven't we figured this out yet? They were grown ass adults. They should know who they actually were. And also, they were working as comedians at that point, and they thought it might be good material, which-- we'll see.
事实证明，有一个办法可以弄清楚。大约在 40 岁的时候——兰迪不记得具体是什么时候——他们潜在的身份互换的话题又被提出来了。他们想，为什么我们还没弄清楚这个？他们是成年人了。他们应该知道他们实际上是谁。而且，当时他们正以喜剧演员为生，他们认为这可能是很好的素材，嗯——我们拭目以待。
Randy thought maybe the hospital where they were born would have a copy of their baby fingerprints. They could get those and compare them to their adult fingerprints. He wasn't wrong about the science part of that. Identical twins have nearly the same DNA, so their fingerprint patterns are very similar-- closer than anyone else's.
兰迪想，也许他们出生的医院会有婴儿指纹的副本。他们可以拿到那些指纹，并把它们与成人的指纹进行比较。他关于科学部分的推断没错。同卵双胞胎几乎有相同的 DNA，所以他们的指纹图案非常相似——比任何其他人都更接近。
As you probably know, fingerprints are made up of lines. And some of those lines have tiny variations in them, like forks or loops. And those markings are different between identical twins. For those of you still listening, the reason for that is that the markings develop based on the conditions in the womb, like pressure, which is different depending on where the baby is in the womb.
正如你可能知道的那样，指纹由线条组成。其中一些线条有微小的变化，比如叉状或环状。这些标记在同卵双胞胎之间是不同的。对于还在听的各位，原因是这些标记的发展基于子宫内的状况，比如压力，这取决于婴儿在子宫里的位置而有所不同。
So Randy called the hospital where they were born to see if they still had a copy of their fingerprints. The hospital told them that they throw birth records out after 30 years. They were old and out of luck.
所以兰迪给他们出生的医院打了电话，看他们是否还有指纹的副本。医院告诉他们，出生记录超过 30 年就会被丢弃。他们年龄大了，没指望了。
Until I was back home last summer with my family--
直到去年夏天我带家人回家——
This is Randy.
这是兰迪。
--and I was digging through, just looking at stuff--
——我在翻找，只是看着东西——
In St. Louis.
在圣路易斯。
--in St. Louis. I was back in our childhood home that we had lived in since we were four years old. And I found from the hospital our footprints. I couldn't believe it.
——在圣路易斯。我回到了我们从四岁起就住的童年旧居。我发现了医院留下的我们的足迹。我简直不敢相信。
Where were they?
它们在哪里？
They were in a book--
它们在一本书里——
A chest--
一个箱子里——
--inside of the--
——在那个……里面——
--next to your bed, right?
——就在你的床边，对吧？
Next to my bed, there was like a nightstand thing that was like a chest that you could open up. And it was just in the bottom of that. I couldn't believe it. And I'd never seen it there before. And I thought, OK, we could find out. It became more real.
在床边，有一个像床头柜一样的箱子，可以打开。它就在箱底。我简直不敢相信。我以前从来没在那里见过它。我想，好的，我们可以找到真相了。它变得更真实了。
Real, and the possibility was rekindled.
真实，而且这种可能性被重新点燃了。
If they could find someone to compare their adult footprints to their baby footprints, maybe they could put this mystery to bed once and for all. As luck would have it, there was just such a person in Buena Park, California, about 25 miles from Los Angeles where Jason and Randy now live-- a forensic identification specialist by the name of Kurt Kuhn.
如果他们能找到人把他们的成人足迹和婴儿足迹进行比较，也许他们就能一劳永逸地解决这个谜团。巧合的是，在加州布埃纳帕克（Buena Park）就有这样一个人，离杰森和兰迪现在住的洛杉矶大约 25 英里——一位名叫库尔特·库恩（Kurt Kuhn）的法医鉴定专家。
But Kurt said there was no way he could use a baby footprint from a hospital. Those aren't made for identification purposes, they're made because baby feet are freaking cute. They're mementos, and they usually don't have much detail.
但库尔特说，他不可能使用医院的婴儿足迹。那些不是为了鉴定目的制作的，它们之所以存在是因为婴儿的脚可爱到爆。它们是纪念品，通常没有多少细节。
In June, Jason sent Kurt the footprints anyway, just to check. And when Kurt saw them, he confirmed that they were mostly just unusable smudges of ink. But miraculously, there was a half-inch spot on the ball of the left Jason foot that had nice, clear lines. He shouldn't have any problem making the identification. He just needed Jason and Randy's adult feet.
六月，杰森还是把足迹寄给了库尔特，只是为了确认一下。当库尔特看到它们时，他确认它们大多只是无法使用的墨迹污点。但奇迹般地，杰森左脚的脚掌上有一块半英寸的地方有清晰的线条。他进行鉴定应该没问题。他只需要杰森和兰迪的成年足迹。
Faced with the imminent revelation of their true identities, Jason and Randy were forced to think through what they would actually do if they'd been switched as babies, which, let's be honest, is not a long list of considerations.
面临即将揭晓真实身份的时刻，杰森和兰迪被迫思考如果他们婴儿时期被调换了他们会做什么，说实话，这并不是一个很长的考量清单。
Do you think you'd swap names?
你觉得你们会交换名字吗？
Or would we legally change our names to each other's names?
还是我们会在法律上把我们的名字改成对方的名字？
Right. If you are swapped, then you're kind of like committing fraud all the time right now.
对。如果你被调换了，那你就像一直在犯欺诈罪。
I guess, yeah.
我猜是吧。
Unintentionally.
无意中。
Unintentional fraud, yeah. Well, I would be using his social security number.
无意中的欺诈，是的。好吧，我会使用他的社会安全号码。
Right.
对。
You know, how does that affect everything we do?
你知道，这会如何影响我们所做的一切？
I wonder if it does. I mean, maybe it only matters if one of you commits murder barefoot, and then runs through wet cement or something.
我不知道是否会。我的意思是，也许只有当你们其中一个人光着脚犯了谋杀罪，然后跑过湿水泥之类的东西时才重要。
Right.
对。
Maybe practically, it doesn't actually matter.
也许实际上，它真的没关系。
That one's out. We can't do that.
那一个出局了。我们不能那样做。
We can't do that now. Thanks a lot.
我们现在不能那样做了。多谢了。
Maybe it doesn't matter. I'm probably right about that. Except there's one person who Jason was legitimately worried about-- their mom, Annette, who they're very close with. Their father died in 2009. Annette's had two strokes in recent years. They're protective of her. What if she got it wrong all those years ago?
也许没关系。我可能是对的。除了有一个人杰森确实合法担心——他们的妈妈安妮特，他们和她很亲。他们的父亲在 2009 年去世了。安妮特近年来两次中风。他们很保护她。如果她多年前搞错了怎么办？
I would feel bad for our mom.
我会为我妈妈感到难过。
Yeah, say more about that.
是的，多说说看。
I would feel like maybe she would be embarrassed, or maybe she would feel like she should have spoken up and maybe found out a way in that moment to get our footprints and just dispel it and figure it out.
我会觉得也许她会感到尴尬，或者也许她会觉得她当时应该说出来，也许找到一种方法在那个时刻拿到我们的足迹并消除疑虑，把它弄清楚。
Annette, however, was not concerned.
然而，安妮特并不担心。
I just have a feeling, that's all-- my feeling, my definite feeling that I know who's who. I know who you are. I'm the mother. I know.
我只是有种感觉，仅此而已——我的感觉，我确定的感觉，我知道谁是谁。我知道你们是谁。我是母亲。我知道。
What if it's different? You want me to change my name? What if I became Jason and Jason became me?
如果不同呢？你想让我改名吗？如果我变成了杰森，而杰森变成了我呢？
Then you have to have different girlfriends.
那你得换不同的女朋友。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
You mean wives? Mom.
你是说妻子？妈妈。
A few days before Thanksgiving, I flew to LA and met Randy, Jason, and Annette at Randy's house where Annette was spending the holiday. We left her at home with her grandchildren and headed down the 5 towards Buena Park, and hopefully resolution. Randy said he was feeling remarkably zen. But Jason?
感恩节前几天，我飞往洛杉矶，在兰迪家见到了兰迪、杰森和安妮特，安妮特在那里过节。我们把她和孙辈留在家里，沿着 5 号公路前往布埃纳帕克，希望得到答案。兰迪说他感到异常平静。但杰森呢？
I feel more nervous today than ever before about this. Like, I think when we got into this, I was like, oh, this is going to be so interesting and fascinating. But I really want my mom to be right. Like, I want to be me. I don't know. I just woke up this morning saying, god, I hope my mom was right.
我今天比以往任何时候都更紧张。我觉得我们刚开始这事时，我心想，噢，这会非常有趣和引人入胜。但我真的希望我妈妈是对的。我想做我自己。我不知道。我今天早上醒来说，天哪，希望我妈妈是对的。
We turned off the highway, drove through the gates of Kurt's subdivision, and pulled up to a house with a Winnebago out front.
我们下了高速，穿过库尔特小区的大门，停在一栋前面有辆房车（Winnebago）的房子前。
Oh, it's a Winnebago.
噢，那是辆房车。
The garage door was halfway down, and behind it we could see a pair of white legs that ended in a sock tan and flip-flops.
车库门半开着，后面我们能看到一双白腿，末端是袜子留下的印记和人字拖。
Kurt?
库尔特？
The garage door lifted to reveal Kurt--
车库门升起露出库尔特——
What's up?
怎么了？
--a tall man with a full mustache and a voice like a cartoon bear.
——一个身材高大、留着浓密胡子、声音像卡通熊的人。
And you're not coming in through the garage. Get on the front porch. Let me get rid of the trash and take them--
你们别从车库进来。去前门廊。让我把垃圾处理掉然后带他们——
All right.
好的。
Done. Done and doner.
搞定。搞定了。
We stepped into Kurt's living room, met his wife and granddaughter.
我们走进库尔特的客厅，见到了他的妻子和孙女。
Hey, I'm Jason. Nice to meet you.
嘿，我是杰森。很高兴见到你。
We made an impressive amount of small talk about Thanksgiving, Winnebagos, hunting.
我们进行了令人印象深刻的关于感恩节、房车、打猎的寒暄。
Well, have you ever bitten into birdshot while eating?
嗯，你吃的时候被鸟弹击中过吗？
I have not, no.
我没，没有。
I have, actually.
事实上我被击中过。
So-- [LAUGHS]
所以——[笑]
Kurt spent 25 and a half years working as a forensic identification specialist for the Beverly Hills and Los Angeles Police Departments.
库尔特花了 25 年半的时间作为比佛利山庄和洛杉矶警察局的法医鉴定专家工作。
There it is right there, yep.
就在那儿，是的。
He shows us Jason and Randy's baby footprints. He'd had them locked in his safe for five months.
他向我们展示了杰森和兰迪的婴儿足迹。他把它们锁在他的保险箱里五个月了。
Take those.
拿着那些。
Oh, they're so cute.
噢，它们太可爱了。
It's time to take their adult footprints.
该取他们的成人足迹了。
All right, so what do we do?
好的，那我们该做什么？
Sit down and get rid of a left shoe and sock.
坐下，脱掉左脚鞋袜。
Randy goes first. He puts his naked foot up on Kurt's knee. Kurt takes a special ink pad and presses it against his foot. Then he repeats the process with Jason. And that's it. We send them out the door to walk around the neighborhood while Kurt figures out who is actually Jason and who is actually Randy.
兰迪先来。他把赤裸的脚放在库尔特的膝盖上。库尔特拿了一个特殊的墨水垫按在他的脚上。然后他在杰森身上重复了这个过程。就是这样。我们让他们出门在附近走动，而库尔特则弄清楚谁是杰森，谁是兰迪。
We go upstairs to his office where he scans the footprints and then pulls them up on his computer screen. He enlarges the baby one onscreen, because it's teeny, and stares at the lines comparing it to the adult footprint. After just 20 minutes, he's done. I text Jason and tell him to come back to the house.
我们去楼上的办公室，他扫描了足迹，然后在电脑屏幕上调出它们。他放大了婴儿的足迹，因为它太小了，盯着线条并将其与成人足迹进行比较。仅仅 20 分钟后，他完成了。我发短信给杰森，告诉他回房子。
OK, here we go.
好的，我们开始吧。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Kurt sits them back down on the couch and proceeds with a line of questioning I had not anticipated.
库尔特让他们坐回沙发，开始了一个我没预料到的问答环节。
OK. Well, my first question is how many other babies were in the doctor's office that day?
好的。嗯，我的第一个问题是那天医生办公室里还有多少婴儿？
I have no idea.
我不知道。
Kurt, who's one of the nicest guys you'll ever meet, by the way, is screwing with them.
库尔特，顺便说一句，他是你见过的最友善的人之一，正在逗他们玩。
[INAUDIBLE] OK, let's hear it. Don't keep us in suspense.
[听不清] 好的，说吧。别让我们一直悬着心。
So he tells them.
于是他告诉了他们。
Wow. Whoa. My god.
哇。天哪。上帝啊。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
Thanks, Kurt.
谢谢，库尔特。
All right, safe travels. Have a good trip, you guys.
好的，祝旅途平安。你们路上小心。
Thanks.
谢谢。
Thank you. We'll be in touch soon, OK?
谢谢。我们很快会联系的，好吗？
And you have a safe flight home.
祝你们飞行平安回家。
Oh.
噢。
Oh, my god.
噢，天哪。
I'll turn off the air.
我要关掉空调。
No, I'm not going to tell you the results yet. On the drive back to Randy's house, their family calls. First, Randy's wife Amy who asks him not how are you, but who are you.
不，我还不会告诉你们结果。在开车回兰迪家的路上，他们的家人打了电话。首先是兰迪的妻子艾米，她没问你好吗，而是问你是谁。
Hey.
嘿。
Who are you?
你是谁？
Then Randy's daughter Georgia calls with her sister and Jason's kids in the background.
然后兰迪的女儿乔治亚打电话来，背景里有她妹妹和杰森的孩子。
Are you you?
你是你吗？
I'm going to reveal it when I get home.
等我回家再揭晓。
OK, wait. But can we go to the mall?
好的，等下。但我们可以去商场吗？
Can we go to the mall, please?
我们可以去商场吗，拜托？
[DOOR OPENING]
[门开声]
We're home. Come on down.
我们到家了。快下来。
Come on in.
快进来。
We walk back into the kitchen we left a few hours before. Annette is there with her four grandchildren. Jason and Randy's aunt and uncle are there too and an English bulldog named Roman. We gather around the kitchen island. Jason's five-year-old daughter, Noah, clings to him. Everyone's excited, a little nervous.
我们走回几个小时前离开的厨房。安妮特和她的四个孙辈在那里。杰森和兰迪的姨妈和姨夫也在，还有一只叫罗曼的英国斗牛犬。我们聚在厨房岛周围。杰森五岁的女儿诺亚紧紧贴着他。每个人都很兴奋，有点紧张。
First of all-- OK, so first of all, how is everyone feeling?
首先——好的，首先，大家感觉如何？
Good. Oh, good! Just get to the point!
好。噢，好！赶紧说重点！
I'm nervous.
我很紧张。
We got the results, and we found out that I am me and Uncle Jason is Uncle Jason.
我们拿到了结果，发现我是我，杰森叔叔是杰森叔叔。
[CHEERING]
[欢呼声]
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
I'm so glad. You actually saw it, for sure.
我真高兴。你确实看到了，确定了。
This is great.
太棒了。
We don't have to think about it. But that's what I thought in my heart. I felt like--
我们不必再想它了。但我心里一直那么想。我觉得——
So doesn't that make you feel like-- what does it make you feel like, that you got it--
那难道不让你觉得——这让你觉得什么，你弄对了——
Just in my heart, it felt like that's who you were, when you're a mother. And now I'm excited. [LAUGHING] I'm happy.
就在心里，感觉那就是你，作为母亲的时候。现在我很兴奋。[笑] 我很开心。
You feel good?
你感觉好吗？
I'm excited.
我很兴奋。
I love that you're so happy.
我喜欢你这么开心的样子。
I'm so happy.
我太开心了。
So we went down, and he did our footprint. I know. Look, she's really so happy. She's like legitimately happy. Look at the smile on Mom's face. She's so happy.
所以我们去了，他做了我们的足迹。我知道。看，她真的太开心了。她真的是心满意足地开心。看妈妈脸上的笑容。她太开心了。
A day later, Randy got Aunt Linda on the phone and told her the good news.
一天后，兰迪给琳达阿姨打电话，告诉了她这个好消息。
Yahoo!
雅虎！
Yahoo. So that means that Mom and Dad were right.
雅虎。所以那意味着妈妈和爸爸是对的。
Well, they had a 50/50 chance.
嗯，他们有一半的几率。
That's right. Thank you, Aunt Linda. Love you.
那倒是。谢谢，琳达阿姨。爱你。
I love you too.
我也爱你。
So all is well in the Sklar family. Jason is still older than Randy by five minutes. Randy is still the one who spent time in an incubator. They haven't been committing unintentional fraud. They don't have to change their social security numbers. The world Annette said they were living in was indeed the world they were in all along.
所以斯克拉家族一切安好。杰森仍然比兰迪大五分钟。兰迪依然是那个在保温箱里度过时光的人。他们没有进行无意的欺诈。他们不必更改社会安全号码。安妮特所说的他们一直生活在其中的世界，确实是他们一直生活在其中的世界。
Dana Chivvis is one of the producers of our show.
达娜·奇维斯是我们节目的制作人之一。
Act 4, If I Lived Here, I'd Be Home Now. So our last story today is about somebody who tries to visit a parallel world, one that she almost lived in herself. Diane Wu explains.
第四幕，《如果我住在这里，我现在就到家了》。今天我们的最后一个故事是关于一个试图访问一个平行世界的人，一个她差点就生活在其中的世界。黛安·吴（Diane Wu）来解释。
The universe Emily ended up in was like a postcard for old-timey America-- 10 acres in Vermont with five big brothers and sisters eating candy out of glass jars at the family general store.
艾米丽（Emily）最终进入的那个宇宙就像一张老式美国的明信片——在佛蒙特州有 10 英亩地，五个哥哥姐姐在家庭杂货店吃着玻璃罐里的糖果。
Yeah, we just lived in this big house. And my parents were really strict. [LAUGHS] My parents were so strict. They always reminded me of the Von Trapp family, even though that's really extreme.
是的，我们住在这一所大房子里。我父母真的很严厉。[笑] 我父母太严厉了。他们总是让我想到冯·特拉普（Von Trapp）家族，尽管那有点太极端。
Mm-hmm. A lot of rules, huh?
嗯。很多规矩，对吧？
It was a lot of rules. It was very much do as I say.
有很多规矩。基本上就是“照我说的做”。
She almost lived a totally different life. Emily was adopted from South Korea when she was a baby. She's 40 now. And as a kid, she rarely thought about the world she came from, what her life would have been like there. It was the '80s. That kind of thing wasn't especially encouraged. Her family raised her not to ask many questions about her past, but there was one thing she really wanted to know about it.
她差点过上完全不同的生活。艾米丽是婴儿时被从韩国领养的。她现在 40 岁。小时候，她很少思考她来自的世界，在那里的生活会是什么样子。那是 80 年代。那种事情并不特别受鼓励。她的家人抚养她时尽量不去问关于她过去的太多问题，但有一件事她真的很想知道。
I mean, mostly growing up I just really wondered what my birth mother looked like.
我的意思是，成长过程中我大多只是真的很想知道我的亲生母亲长什么样。
Mm-hmm.
嗯。
That was usually the question that always came to my mind.
那通常是我脑子里一直出现的问题。
Her adoptive parents didn't look like her. They were white, as was most everybody else in town, so it was hard for her to picture her birth mother's face. But there was no one to ask.
她的领养父母长得不像她。他们是白人，就像镇上几乎所有人一样，所以她很难想象亲生母亲的脸。但没人可以问。
A couple of decades later, Emily became a mother herself and suddenly, felt connected to and curious about her birth mother again. She started researching how to contact her and, two long years later, finally got in touch.
几十年后，艾米丽自己也成了母亲，突然又感觉到与亲生母亲的联系和好奇。她开始研究如何联系她，两年后，终于取得了联系。
Then she decided to go on a trip to South Korea to meet her birth mother-- a trip that would allow her to tunnel between the universe that was into the universe that might have been. She recorded parts of it for a podcast called, Motherhood Sessions. All of Emily's emotions about the trip hit her on the way to the airport in New York when suddenly she found herself sobbing while talking to the cab driver.
然后她决定去韩国见她的亲生母亲——一趟能让她在已有的宇宙和可能存在的宇宙之间穿梭的旅行。她为播客《母亲会议》（Motherhood Sessions）录制了部分片段。艾米丽对这次旅行的所有情绪在去纽约机场的路上爆发了，当时她突然在与出租车司机交谈时哭了起来。
Do you have any family in Korea?
你在韩国有家人吗？
I'm meeting my birth mother for the first time.
我要第一次见我的亲生母亲。
That is exciting for you. Who told about your birth mother?
这对你来说很令人兴奋。谁告诉你的亲生母亲？
I searched for her through the adoption agency. It took two years-- two years of searching.
我通过领养机构找到了她。花了两年时间——两年的寻找。
Oh, that's good. That's good. And what about your dad?
噢，那很好。那很好。那你的父亲呢？
I don't know.
我不知道。
You don't know?
你不知道？
I don't know.
我不知道。
OK, don't worry about that anything. It should be better, everything. And it's a very blessing for you. You're going to meet your mother. I know. I know you're feeling, because you've spend your whole life without your mom.
没关系，别担心。一切都会好起来的。这对你来说是一种巨大的祝福。你要去见你的母亲。我知道。我知道你的感受，因为你一生都在没有妈妈的情况下度过。
[SOBS]
[抽泣]
I know you spent your whole life without your mom. You need your mom on when your children-- like you babies, you know?
我知道你一生都没有妈妈。当你有孩子的时候你真的需要妈妈——就像你的孩子那样，你知道吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Going on the plane, too, for me, it was kind of thinking about the last time I took that flight was when I was a baby. And touching down, I remember thinking that the last time I was here was when I was five months old.
上飞机对我来说，也是在想最后一次坐那次航班是我婴儿的时候。落地时，我记得想到我最后一次来这里是我五个月大的时候。
She had a day to settle in before she met her birth mother. It was the first time she'd ever been to Asia. And wandering around Seoul, it was so easy to imagine the other versions of her life all around her.
在见亲生母亲之前，她有一天的调整时间。这是她第一次去亚洲。漫步在首尔，想象她周围各种版本的自己生活太容易了。
I'd go in stores, or in restaurants, and I'd think, oh, could I be that woman behind the counter working there? When I'd see a mom with her little girl, I'd be like, oh, wow, is that what it would've been like to walk down the street holding my mom's hand?
我走进商店或餐馆，会想，噢，我能不能是那个在柜台工作的女人？当我看到一个带着小女孩的妈妈，我会想，噢，哇，如果拉着我妈的手在街上走会是什么样？
On her second day in Korea, Emily carefully did her hair and makeup and headed to the adoption agency to meet her birth mother. Their reunion happened in a worn down meeting room in front of a bulletin board pinned with Christmas cards.
她在韩国的第二天，艾米丽仔细梳妆打扮，前往领养机构见她的亲生母亲。她们的重逢发生在一个破旧的会议室里，前面是一块贴着圣诞卡的公告板。
I see this short Korean woman walk in the door. And we hug, and I cry a lot.
我看到这个矮小的韩国女人走进门。我们拥抱，我大哭了一场。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
And she says [KOREAN], which means I'm sorry.
她说“（韩语）”，意思是“我很抱歉”。
It's the very first thing her birth mother says to her.
这是她亲生母亲对她说的第一句话。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]. And I say [KOREAN], which means it's OK. [KOREAN]
（韩语）。我说“（韩语）”，意思是“没关系”。（韩语）
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
It's like looking in a mirror.
这就像照镜子一样。
[SPEAKING KOREAN]
[说韩语]
That's a social worker in the room translating for them. Emily's birth mother told her her story. She'd gotten pregnant as a teenager, which was completely shunned. There was no place in society for teenage single mothers.
那是房间里的社工为她们翻译。艾米丽的亲生母亲告诉了她她的故事。她十几岁时怀孕，这受到了彻底的蔑视。社会上没有未婚未成年母亲的一席之地。
A few days after Emily was born, a relative came by with a police officer and social worker, and they took Emily away. A week later, Emily's birth mother went to the police station, desperate to get her baby back. They told her it was too late.
艾米丽出生几天后，一位亲戚带着警察和社工来了，他们带走了艾米丽。一周后，艾米丽的亲生母亲赶到警察局，渴望要回她的孩子。他们告诉她太迟了。
She called the adoption agency several times over the years to check in on her daughter. Learned she'd been adopted by an American family. I talked with her on the phone. And when I asked her if she'd ever imagine the world where she did manage to get Emily back, she told me, I haven't really had those thoughts, but I always dreamt about her.
多年来她多次打电话给领养机构询问女儿的情况。得知她被一个美国家庭领养了。我和她在电话里聊过。当我问她是否想象过她成功要回艾米丽的世界时，她告诉我，我没有真正那样想过，但我一直梦到她。
Seeing her birth mother's face, meeting her whole extended family later on that trip, it had a profound impact on Emily. I heard her talk about it on that podcast, Motherhood Sessions. And I was surprised and moved to hear her say that being in the same room with her birth family--
看到亲生母亲的脸，在那次旅行后期见到她所有的大家族，对艾米丽产生了深远的影响。我在那个播客《母亲会议》里听到她谈论这件事。当她听到她身处亲生家庭的同一个房间时，我感到惊讶和感动——
For the first time, I felt pretty, you know? Because growing up, your parents always tell you that you're pretty, or whatever. But I never really believed it. But being around this family, and we all look alike, you know? I felt like I was beautiful. And I had never felt it that deeply before.
这是我第一次觉得我很漂亮，你知道吗？因为成长过程中，你的父母总是告诉你你很漂亮，无论如何。但我从来没真正相信过。但和这个家庭在一起，我们看起来都一样，你知道吗？我觉得我是美丽的。我以前从未如此深刻地感觉到它。
And what do you think is behind that feeling?
你认为这种感觉背后的原因是什么？
Because after growing up, living a lifetime of feeling like you don't fit in and wondering why maybe certain guys don't like you, or why maybe you're not the most popular person in school. You know, for the first time in my life, I felt like I made sense. I felt like my being made sense. I felt like my face made sense.
因为成长过程中，生活在一种觉得自己不合群的感觉里，想知道为什么有些男生不喜欢你，或者为什么你可能不是学校里最受欢迎的人。你知道，这是我人生中第一次，我觉得我有了意义。我觉得我的存在有了意义。我觉得我的脸有了意义。
Emily stayed with her birth family for three days in a town called Dongducheon in a little house by the railroad tracks. There were ceramic pots of kimchi in the yard, a flat screen TV in the living room that was always playing Korean variety shows and soap operas. Lots of visitors came by to welcome Emily. It felt warm, familiar.
艾米丽在铁轨旁的一个小房子里，和一个叫东豆川（Dongducheon）的小镇，和她的亲生家庭住了三天。院子里有装满泡菜的陶瓷缸，客厅里有一台总在播放韩国综艺节目和肥皂剧的平板电视。许多游客来看望艾米丽。感觉很温暖，很熟悉。
On the first night, Emily was getting ready for bed, and her birth mother came in and presented her with four boxes containing gold jewelry for Emily, her kids, and her husband. Emily accepted them, hesitantly. Then using a translation app, her birth mother told her--
第一晚，艾米丽准备睡觉，亲生母亲走进来送给她四个盒子，里面装着给艾米丽、她孩子和她丈夫的金首饰。艾米丽犹豫着接受了。然后使用翻译软件，她的亲生母亲告诉她——
She said Korean mothers sleep with their children. And I'm like, oh, god, here we go.
她说韩国母亲和孩子一起睡。我心想，噢，天哪，来了。
Emily had heard about this-- that it's not unusual for Korean parents to sleep in the same room as their kids, even when they're adults. In this room, there was only one bed. She tried to explain to her birth mother, sorry, but I prefer to sleep alone. It wasn't clicking. Emily ended up calling an interpreter she'd hired who had already gone home for the day.
艾米丽听说过这个——韩国父母即使在孩子成年后也和孩子住同一个房间并不罕见。在这个房间里，只有一张床。她试图向亲生母亲解释，抱歉，但我更喜欢一个人睡。这解释不通。艾米丽最终给她雇的一位已经下班的翻译打了电话。
And so I called her and asked her to explain that I couldn't do it. And she did, but you could see that my birth mother was pissed and not really happy about it. She had missed years and years of my life. I can understand why she'd want to sleep in the same room with me, but I just couldn't do it.
所以我打电话给她请她解释我做不到。她照做了，但你能看出来我亲生母亲很生气，很不高兴。她错过了我生命中好多年。我可以理解为什么她想和我住同一个房间，但我就是做不到。
A lot of the time with her birth mother was like this. As a visitor, it was impossible to fit in completely. She was a stranger and family all at the same time, dropping into a place that really felt like it could be home-- but it wasn't.
和她亲生母亲在一起的大部分时间都是这样。作为一个访客，完全融入是不可能的。她既是陌生人又是家人，进入一个感觉确实可以成为家的地方——但这并不是家。
Diane Wu is our show's managing editor. That podcast, Motherhood Sessions, where we first heard Emily's story, it's a show about women and moms in moments of crisis and change. It starts its second season this week.
黛安·吴是我们节目的执行编辑。那个播客《母亲会议》，我们第一次听到艾米丽故事的地方，是一个关于女性和母亲在危机和变化时刻的节目。它本周开始了第二季。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING) In my alternate universe, things only get better, not worse. There's not a cloud in the deep blue sky, and I'm floating along.
（歌唱）在我的平行宇宙里，事物只会变得更好，不会变糟。湛蓝的天空没有一丝云朵，我正随风漂浮。
Our program was produced today by our executive editor, David Kestenbaum. The people who made today's show include Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Neil Drumming, Nora Gill, Damien Graves, Seth Lind, Jessica Lussenhop, Lina Misitzis, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Julie Whitaker. Our managing editor is Diane Wu.
我们的节目由执行编辑大卫·克斯滕鲍姆制作。参与制作今天节目的人员包括艾尔娜·贝克（Elna Baker）、苏珊·伯顿（Susan Burton）、本·卡尔霍恩（Ben Calhoun）、达娜·奇维斯（Dana Chivvis）、肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）、尼尔·德拉明（Neil Drumming）、诺拉·吉尔（Nora Gill）、达米安·格雷夫斯（Damien Graves）、塞思·林德（Seth Lind）、杰西卡·卢森霍普（Jessica Lussenhop）、莉娜·米西齐斯（Lina Misitzis）、斯托·尼尔森（Stowe Nelson）、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多（Katherine Rae Mondo）、纳迪亚·雷曼（Nadia Reiman）、罗宾·塞米恩（Robyn Semien）、莉莉·沙利文（Lilly Sullivan）、克里斯托弗·斯威塔拉（Christopher Swetala）、马特·蒂尔尼（Matt Tierney）和朱莉·惠特克（Julie Whitaker）。我们的执行编辑是黛安·吴。
Special thanks today to Sean Carroll, the physicist at Caltech, who told David about the universe splitter app in the first place. His book about parallel universes created by quantum physics is called, Something Deeply Hidden.
今天特别感谢加州理工学院的物理学家肖恩·卡罗尔（Sean Carroll），他首先向大卫介绍了“宇宙分裂器”应用。他关于量子物理创造的平行宇宙的书名是《极其深奥的隐秘》（Something Deeply Hidden）。
Thanks also today to Peter Bresnan, Alexandra Sacks, Suebee Craig, Christine Lee, Kim Park Nelson, Andrew Parsons, Eric Daniels, Joe Magee, Nazanin Rafsanjani, Devon Taylor, Emma Munger, and Molly Donahue.
今天还要感谢彼得·布雷斯南（Peter Bresnan）、亚历山德拉·萨克斯（Alexandra Sacks）、苏比·克雷格（Suebee Craig）、克里斯汀·李（Christine Lee）、金·帕克·尼尔森（Kim Park Nelson）、安德鲁·帕森斯（Andrew Parsons）、埃里克·丹尼尔斯（Eric Daniels）、乔·马吉（Joe Magee）、纳扎宁·拉夫桑贾尼（Nazanin Rafsanjani）、德文·泰勒（Devon Taylor）、艾玛·蒙格（Emma Munger）和莫莉·多纳霍（Molly Donahue）。
Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Special thanks as always to our programs co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know, he put a lojack on his car, but not a good one. When his car got stolen, he starts tracking it, and it shows his car, but--
我们的网站是 ThisAmericanLife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换中心（PRX）分发给公共广播电台。特别感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia）先生。你知道，他在车上装了定位器，但装得不好。当他的车被偷时，他开始追踪它，它显示了他的车，但是——
It actually goes left and right at the same time.
它实际上同时向左和向右去了。
Or-- or, everyone, alternative universe photon firing, here we go.
或者——或者，大家，替代宇宙光子发射，我们开始吧。
[ROCKET FIRING]
[火箭发射声]
Torey Malatia, he is so obsessed with the polls for the Democratic primary. But you know, I don't think he really understands how to read them. He was explaining to me the other day that this poll of the electorate in New Hampshire--
托瑞·马拉蒂亚，他太痴迷于民主党初选的民调了。但你知道，我不认为他真的懂得如何解读它们。前几天他向我解释新罕布什尔州的选民民调时——
It actually goes left and right at the same time.
它实际上同时向左和向右去了。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周回来带来更多《美国生活》的故事。
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[音乐播放]
(SINGING) In my alternate universe.
（歌唱）在我的平行宇宙里。